>> Hi, this is Amitbah Bachchan and I'm from
India. I live in Mumbai. I'm an actor and
I've been an actor for the last 40 years.
I've done about approximately 150 films and
I'm very honored to her in Davos. I've been
invited here because there was Economic Forum
is very kindly decided to honor me with their
Crystal Award for my achievement and contribution
in arts [inaudible]. I really don't know how
credible that is as far as I'm concerned because
I just look upon myself as just another actor.
If I have been able to contribute in some
manner to the community of entertainment in
my country then I feel very honored to be
here in Davos and very humbly accept this
award that they are giving me. I've just been
here a few hous and therefore it's very difficult
for me to make out what Davos is all about.
One reads about it, one's heard about it and
has had the opportunity to very briefly to
move around and I find a great amount of energy
and interest among people from different walks
of life, from businesses, from entertainment
and politics, talking, meeting, discussing
issues and I think that this is a wonderful
wonderful occassion. For the entire world
to almost converge in one city, one center,
to be able to air and give their opinions
on views that effect all of us. Whether we
live in India or the United States of America
or Switzerland and we all have our point of
views and this is an extremely important form
for all of us to express ourselves. I know
that we have opportunities individually to
do something like this, but I think once all
of us get together and have a forum, a common
forum, where we can virtually talk to each
other across the table this lends a lot more
credibility. It also becomes a lot more important
because what is talked of, what is discussed
here goes out to the rest of the universe.
I hope that this conference, this forum does
exactly that. I hope valuable topics are discussed
and I hope that those that listen in are able
to gather something, imbibe something from
this and make it a success. If there's something
that needs to be talked about in entertainment,
I'm here and if you have any questions, please
put them forward. Thank you.